nueve meses después El Recuerdo del 6 de
enero de 2021 sigue latente en Estados
Unidos y despierta con cada paso de las
investigaciones judiciales y políticas
que buscan esclarecer el asalto al
Capitolio cuando cientos de personas
intentaron impedir por la fuerza la
ratificación en el senado de los
resultados electorales que llevaron a
Joe biden y a kamala Harris a la casa
blanca
el presidente de Estados Unidos incitó
una insurrección Armada contra Estados
Unidos la profanación del Capitolio que
es el templo de nuestra democracia
estadounidense y la violencia atacando
el congreso son horrores que mancharán
la memoria de nuestra nación para
siempre
de inmediato Nancy pelosi Joe biden
entre otros atribuyeron la investigación
del asalto al Entonces todavía
presidente Donald Trump al discurso del
odio repetido durante sus cuatro años de
mandato así como a las palabras que
pronunció ese mismo 6 de enero en un
acto en Washington cuando todavía
denunciaba un supuesto fraude electoral
no nos atrevamos a llamar los
manifestantes eran asaltantes
insurrectos terroristas domésticos así
de simple
y me gustaría poder decir que no
podíamos ver venir pero no es verdad lo
podíamos ver venir los últimos cuatro
años hemos tenido un presidente que ha
desafiado nuestra democracia nuestra
Constitución nuestra justicia de forma
Clara en todos sus actos
a raíz del asalto los demócratas
intentaron un impeachment para evitar
que Trump terminara sus últimas semanas
de mandato no lo consiguieron ahora la
comisión del senado y el departamento de
Justicia buscan la manera de que trami
su círculo rindan cuentas